the farle is just being if you were part
of it it'd be impossible to follow the
rules the rules just go in a circle it
just becomes a snake eating its own tail
I don't even know what they stand for
and I certainly don't know what they're
going to replace when they tear down a
statue of George Washington I'd like to
know what they want to replace it with
besides an Ever evolving idea of of some
inner feeling the Le only honor that we
know what they want to replace with I
mean have you seen well no it's it's
worse than that in a way because have
you seen some of the statues they' up in
some democrat cities it's the worst sort
of modern contemporary art that means
nothing and that's
in it's like it's like you know it's
like a fist in a cube that is missing a
finger like it makes no sense but that's
part of it because they have to also
break Beauty deconstructionist kind of
exactly